Well, thank you very much.
I just want to say this is a very exciting day for our country.
We have been at this long and hard for three and a half years.
I want to thank Elon who's has been a friend of mine for a long time,...
...somebody I have great respect for.
This has been your baby.
This is the top focus by far.
This is the toughest one.
In fact, that I told my team it's not simply the top priority,...
...it is the only priority.
That's great.
Well, it looks beautiful.
We won't say congratulations because we have a long way to go,...
...but it looks magnificent,...
...and I just want to thank everybody in the room.
Jim, you took it over from its infancy,...
...and I was saying before, they had grass growing in the runways between the cracks...
...and now, we have the best, the best of the best.
And I want to thank again Vice President Mike Pence.
He's worked so hard.
It's been a labor of love,...
...and great job, really, great job.
I want to thank everybody down here,...
...and this is something the First Lady and I look very much forward to seeing.
And in a short while, that's going to be a lift off.
It looks like we're probably going to make it weather wise.
Jim, is that right?
We are a go for launch right now.
That sounds very exciting,...
...so I hope you all enjoy it.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for being here.